il vient d'arrêter malheur a tempéré
tu seras plus tout seul maintenant tu
vas venir vivre avec nom et ton cousin
michael
[Musique]
tu m'as dit que tu bosses pour michael
moi pas tu sais ce qu'on fait j'ai
toujours cru que c'était différent tu as
tant que ça
[Musique]
qui te tirer dessus et ça me tape au
nord
si tu leur donnes pas ce qu'ils veulent
tu sais très bien ce qui va se passer il
faut que tu sois de mon côté tu es mon
frère et tu comptes faire quoi à temps
les italiens sont dans la place depuis
quoi près d'un siècle
et toi tu vas y mettre fin
[Musique]
il y aurait moyen je sais pas oublié
cette histoire non est ce que toi aussi
t'es qu'un pauvre crétin d'irlandais
[Musique]
étaient complets
tu agis comme si tu avais honte que tous
les mois en soi koussa
ton avis qui a balancé tombé à l'eau
aucune idée
ce bois
[Musique]